>>> WHAT IS UP, EVERYONE,
WELCOME TO A SPECIAL WILD CARD
WEEKEND EDITION OF "THE SQUAD,"
WE ARE LIVE IN THE
BLEACHERREPORT PRESENTED BY
DRAFT KINGS.
GR
GREG, USUALLY YOU GIVE AWAY
HOODIES ON THE SHOW.
AND MAYBE AN NFL JERSEY GIFT
CARD OR TWO.
I KNOW YOU HAVE A LOT UP YOUR
SLEEVE, LET THEM KNOW WHAT YOU
ARE GIVING AWAY.
>> CONNOR, WE ARE GIVING AWAY A
LOT, WE ARE GIVING AWAY OVER A
THOUSAND DK DOLLARS, WE HAVE
CUSTOM ODDS BOOST FROM OUR
FRIENDS OVER AT TRAFT KINGS.
HOODIES, JERSEYS, AND AT THE END
OF THE SHOW, THE VERY END OF THE
SHOW, SO, PLEASE STICK AROUND TO
THE END OF THE SHOW, WE ARE
GIVING AWAY AN iPHONE 13,
CONNOR.
YES, AN AYiPHONE 13, I DON'T HA
ONE, DO YOU?
>> I JUST GOT ONE AND I WILL BE
PAYING THAT BILL FOR A LONG
TIME.
IT'S THE BEST GIVE AWAY THAT YOU
COULD HAVE FOR THE SHOW.
IT'S A LOT OF GOOD STUFF.
YOU WANT TO HANG AROUND.
YOU WANT TO BE IN THE COMMENTS.
YOU WILL WANT TO GIVE US YOUR
LOCKS AND TAKES.
I DON'T CARE, WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO SAY.
GET CRAZY IN THERE, LET'S HAVE
FUN.
NORMALLY, THIS IS A TIME WHERE
WE SHARE OUR FAVORITE LOCK
LEGEND VIDEOS FROM LAST WEEK.
BUT TODAY, WE SAID IT ALREADY.
IT'S A SPECIAL OCCASION.
WE WILL DO THINGS A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY.
LET'S LOOK AT THE FAVORITE LOCK
LEGEND VIDEOS FROM THIS REGULAR
SEASON.
♪ ♪
>> LOOKING UP.
HE IS A SIZZLE, AND THIS GUY IS
CRISPY.
>> IT'S THE LOCK OF THE CENTURY,
HAPPENING THIS VERY WEEKEND.
>> WHO IS DOING IT THIS WEEK?
>> GOING GIVE US A LOT.
>> HE IS COMING BACK WITH THE
GREEN BALL.
>> THE SUN GOD.
LET'S GO.
>> YOU GUYS HAVE TO SEE WHAT I
JUST PULLED IN.
>> LOCK IT IN.
>> COUNT ON HIM TO RUMBLE IN FOR
ONE THIS WEEK.
RIDE WITH THE SQUAD AND CASH
YOUR TICKETS.
>> WE HAVE GOT BUTTERCUP.
WE HAVE ATLAS.
ALL KINDS OF LEGENDS.
AND THAT'S NOT THE ONLY THING WE
ARE SWITCHING UP.
USUALLY THIS IS THE SHOW WHERE
WE ASK YOU EVERY WEEK, WHO IS
GETTING IN THE END ZONE?
WHO IS GOING TO SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN?
BUT WITH OUR FRIENDS AT DRAFT
KINGS, WE ARE SWITCHING UP THE
ODDS.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHO IS THROWING
FOR THE MOST PASSING YARDS ON
WILD CARD WEEKEND AND HERE IS
THE ODDS LIST RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE
DAK PRESCOTT AT THE TOP.
HE IS THE FAVORITE, GOING UP
AGAINST GREG'S 49ers.
THEY KMCOMPLAINED ABOUT THE
CORNERS BEFORE.
PATRICK MAHOMES AND BRADY, EVEN.
STAFFORD, JOE BURROW AT PLUS
7.50.
YOU HAVE TO LOVE HOW THAT IS
LOOKING.
KYLE MURRAY PLUS A THOUSAND.
AND JOSH ALLEN AGAINST A TOUGH
NEW ENGLAND DEFENSE, THE BIGGEST
UNDERDOG THAT MADE THE BOARD
RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW THE DRILL RIGHT NOW.
WITH FOUR LEGENDARY PICKS TO
SHOW YOU, THE LAST ONE STANDING
IS OUR WILD CARD WEEKEND SQUAD
LEADER.
LET'S GET IT GOING.
NO MORE TIME TO WASTE.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE TO BRING IN
THE LEGENDS FOR A SPECIAL
OCCASION LIKE THIS.
LET'S SEE THE CHOICE.
>> WHAT IS UP?
I HEARD -- IS OUT FOR THE MOST
PASSING YARDS THIS WEEKEND.
DAK PRESCOTT IS THE PICK FOR
PLUS 450.
GREG WILL BE HERE TO BOOST THAT.
THAT COULD BE MORE FUN.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE A NEW
CONTENDER.
IT'S THE REAL DAY DAY.
>> WHAT IS UP, WHAT IS UP?
THIS IS YOUR BOY.
PASSING YARDS THIS WEEKEND, WE
ARE GOING TO GO WITH THE MAN
WITH THE PLAN, JOE BURROWS.
LOCK IT IN, IT'S TIME TO EAT.
>> THE REAL DAY-DAY.
LOVE THE BENGALS.
LOVE THE PICK, GREG.
THAT'S HOW YOU MAKE AN ENTRY.
YOU GET ONE FIRST IMPRESSION.
THAT IS HOW IT'S DONE.
GREG, LET THEM KNOW WHAT YOU
NEED.
I WANT TO KNOW HOW YOU ARE
FEELING, WHERE YOUR HEAD IS AT
ON THE FIRST MATCH UP.
PRESCOTT AND BURROW?
>> I GOT YOU, CONNOR.
I GOT YOU.
I NEED EVERYONE IN THE COMMENTS
TO LET US KNOW.
GET IN THE COMMENTS, TYPE OUT
DAK PRESCOTT, TYPE OUT JOE
BURROW, AND LET US KNOW WHICH
WAY YOU ARE RIDING.
I WILL HOP IN ON DAK PRESCOTT.
HE IS THE FAVORITE FOR A REASON.
THE 49ers SECONDARY IS AILING.
THEY ARE STRUGGLING IN THE
CORNER DEPARTMENT TO BE
SPECIFIC.
SO, HE HAS A BUNCH OF NUMBER
ONES THAT HE CAN BE THROWING THE
BALL TO, CONNOR.
BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT THE GAME
AND HOITS ACTUALLY GOING TO PLAY
OUT.
I PERSONALLY THING THE NINERS
WHO LIKE TO RUN THE BALL WILL
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE COWBOYS
DEFENSE WHO ARE STRULING IN
STR
STOP THE RUN.
THEY ARE GOING TO TAKE THE
APPROACH TO THE GAME, SO, THAT
WILL LIMIT DAK'S OPPORTUNITIES
TO SCORE.
THAT PICK IS JUST KIND OF IFFY
FOR ME.
I DO LIKE THE JOE BURROW PICK.
HE IS TAKING ON THE RAIDERS
DEFENSE THAT IS NOT SCARING
ANYONE.
WE KNOW WHAT THE PENGALES LIKE
TO DO.
HE HAS WEAPONS.
JAYMAR CHASE, HE HAS WEAPONS
CONNOR AND WE KNOW WHAT HE LIKES
TO DO.
KNOWS THAT THE BENGALS LIKE TO
DO.
I'M ROCKING WITH JOE BURROW.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
>>LY I'M WITH YOU ALL THE WAY.
I LIKE THE NINERS RUN GAME
DICTATING THE GAME.
AND MAYBE TAKING THE BALL OUT OF
DAK'S HAND'S MORE THAN THEY ARE
USED TO.
THAT HAS TO BE A FEAR P RIGHT?
WE ARE NOT SAYING BECAUSE OF
THAT THE COWBOYS WILL LOSE OR
THE MINORS WILL RUN AWAY WITH
IT.
IT'S AN ASPECT OF POSSESSION
TIME.
YOU SEE IT, IT'S NOT JUST KYLE
SHANAHAN.
MIKE McDANIEL IS GETTING HEAD
COACHING INTERVIEWS FOR A
REASON.
BECAUSE OF THE RUN GAME THEY
HAVE BUILT.
THEY HAVE BUILT IT TO BE READY
FOR THE POSTSEASON AND BECAUSE
OF THE LIMITATIONS AT USU
QUARTERBACK.
I WILL KEEP IT REAL, I LOVE THE
JOE BURROW PICK.
I THINK HE WILL HAVE A BIG TIME
DAY.
I LOVE THE ODDS AT PLUS 750.
THAT FEELS LIKE STEALING.
I'M NOT SAYING HE IS THE
FAVORITE.
I LOVE THAT CHOICE.
I KNOW WE HAVE A COWBOYS
FRIENDLY COMMENT SECTION.
NOTHING WRONG WITH THAT, GREG.
WHERE ARE THEY LEANING ON THIS
ONE?
>> CONNOR, YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE A
COWBOY FRIENDLY COMMENT SECTION.
I HAVE KENNY IN THE COMMENTS HE
HAS A JOE BURROW HERE SITTING AT
LSU SMOKING A CIGAR.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, YOU ARE
WALKING OUT WITH A HOOD AY AND I
SEE SOME DALLAS FANS.
AND SHOUT OUT TO MIKE BOW LEN,
CONNOR, I THINK IT'S TIME TO
MAKE A DECISION.
JAY VARGAS, JAY VARGAS IS THE
LAST ONE.
DAK PRESCOTT, HE IS MOVING ON.
TO THE NEXT ROUND.
DAK PRESCOTT, I'M NOT TOO
SURPRISED.
I KNEW THE COMMENTS WOULD STEER
US TOWARD THE DALLAS SIDE.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE OUR OLD FRIEND
COMES IN WITH THE SELECTION.
AND THE REAL DAY-DAY MAKING A
STRONG CONGRESSIONAL WITH
JOEY-B, WE WILL REVISIT IT
LATER.
ROUND TWO.
TIME TO BRING BACK A FAMILIAR
FACE.
WE HAVE THE PRO ANGLER JB COMING
IN WITH A CHOICE THIS WEEK.
WHAT'S IT GOING TO BE?
>> WENT TO STARBUCKS THIS
MORNING TO GET MY COUGH AND I
THEY ARE HANDING OUT LOCKS OVER
HERE NOW.
SO, WE HAVE PATRICK MAHOMESS,
MOST PASSING YARDS, WEEK ONE OF
THE PLAYOFFS.
LOCK IT IN.
>> THE STARBUCKS BARRISTA HERE.
A HAIR UNDER DAK PRESCOTT, IN
TERMS OF BEING THE FAVORITE
HERE.
IT'S A TOUGH STEELERS DEFENSE.
BUT THE CHIEFS ARE GETTING
HEALTHY RIGHT NOW.
THIS ONE IS ANOTHER CLOSE DOWN
TO THE WIRE CHOICE HERE.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING RIGHT
NOW.
>> WE ALREADY JUMPED IN, HE I
TALKED ABOUT DAK PRESSES COT.
IT'S ABOUT PAT MAHOMES.
HE WILL HOPFU
-- HOPEFULLY
HEALTHY.
HE LIKES TO SPREAD THE BALL
AROUND AND MOVE THE BALL UP THE
FIELD.
SO, I THINK I'M GOING TO ROCK
WITH PAT FACING THAT STEELER
DEFENSE, CONNOR, WHICH WAY ARE
YOU LEANING?
>> I LIKE MAHOMEL
MES AS WELL I
THIS ONE.
IT'S NOT A THING WHERE THE
MATCH-UP SCARES YOU OFF AND WHY
WE MADE THE CASE FOR DAK HERE.
MAHOMES IS GOING TO GET HIT.
DOESN'
DOESN'T MATTER WHO THEY ARE
PLAYING.
MAHOMES WILL BE READY TO GO.
I'M NOT SAYING THE CHIEFS GO OUT
AND GET 400 YARDS.
THERE'S NO REASON HE CAN'T THROW
FOR MORE THAN WHAT DAK DOES THIS
WEEK.
I THINK OUR COMMENTS ARE GOING
TO AGREE ON THIS ONE.
I THINK IT MIGHT BE ENOUGH TO
UNSEAT DAK, WHERE ARE THEY GOING
RIGHT NOW, GREG?
>> CONNOR, I'M IN THE COMMENTS
AND I GOT, HAIR ATTACKS HAS PAT
MAHOMES SPREADING KETCHUP
AROUND.
NATI MAYONAISE IS A LOCK.
THEY ARE FUNNY IN THE COMMENTS.
DANA, DANA GOAL SIX HAS PAT
MAHOMES SWINGING A BAT AND
HITTING A HOME RUN.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYONE THAT I
MENTIONED, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH HOODIES.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY, CONNOR, IT
APPEARS PATRICK MAHOMES IS
MOVING TO THE NEXT ROUND.
>> MAHOMES UNSEATING DAK.
HE HAS ONE MORE CHALLENGER AS WE
ENTER IN TO ROUND THREE.
THE FINAL ROUND CAN DECIDE THE
SQUAD LEADER NOT FOR AN ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN.
BUT FOR MOST PASSING YARDS.
I WILL BRING BACK GOLDBERG ON
THE SHOW.
TRYING TO STEAL IT AT THE END.
WILL WE HAVE AN ATLAS
APPEARANCE?
LET'S SEE.
>> WHAT IS UP?
HE IS GOING TO PICK THIS
WEEKEND'S MOST PASSING YARDS BY
A QUARTERBACK.
--
[ INAUDIBLE ]
>
>>.
>> LOOK AT THAT, IT'S GOING TO
BE JOSH ALLEN.
MOST PASSING YARDS THIS WEEKEND.
>> ATLAS RIDING WITH BILL'S
MAFIA IN THAT FRIGID, FRIGID
WEATHER GAME UP IN BUFFALO.
THAT'S WHY IT'S PLUS 1100 FOR A
REASON, FOLKS.
NO SURPRISE THERE.
SO, WE HAVE MAHOMES PLUS 550,
AND KEEP IN MIND, GREG IS GOING
TO BOOST THE WINNER.
DON'T BE TURNED OFF BY THE ODDS.
JOSH ALLEN A BIG TIME UNDERDOG,
DWREG, YOU TOLD ME BEFORE, YOU
DON'T LIKE THE COLD.
DOES THAT MEAN YOU DON'T LIKE
JOSH ALLEN THIS WEEKEND EITHER?
>> YEAH, CONNOR, I DID TELL YOU
THAT I'M NOT TOO FOND OF THE
COLD AND I HEAR THAT'S WHAT IT'S
GOING TO BE IN BUFFALO.
AND THE LAST TIME, MY THING IS,
CONNOR, THE LAST TIME WE SAW
JOSH ALLEN TAKING ON THE
PATRIOTS DEFENSE IN THE COLD,
JUST DIDN'T LOOK TOO GOOD TO ME.
IT DOES NOT LOOK TOO GOOD TO ME.
I THINK I WILL THE STICK WITH MY
GUY PAT MAHOMES HERE.
STICK TO SOMETHING THAT I HAVE
SEEN BEFORE.
I HAVE SEEN PAT GO OUT AND SLING
IT PLENTY OF TIMES AND ELEMENTS
WILL NOT BE A FACTOR.
I WILL ROCK WITH MY GUY, PAT,
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEARNING?
SG
>> IF IT'S NOT BROERNGS DON'T
TRY TO FIX IT.
NO MATTER THE CIRCUMSTANCE,
RIGHT?
AND THEY ARE, IT'S THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF SPREAD
MATCH UP.
THEY ARE BIG TIME FAVORITES
AGAINST THE STEELERS.
EVEN THOUGH WE LIKE THE STEELERS
DEFENSE.
HE IS GOING TO GET HIS.
I LOVE THE BILLS AND EVEN THIS
WEEKEND TO WIN.
I DON'T KNOW FITS A GAME JOSH
ALLEN COMES OUT AND THROWS FOR
330, 340.
THERE'S QUARTERBACKS THAT ARE
LOOKING MORE PRIME TO FILL UP
THE STAT SHEET THIS WEEK.
GREG, I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE AS CLOSE AS THE FINAL
ROUND USUALLY IS.
BUT I HAVE BEEN VERY WRONG
BEFORE ON THE SHOW.
WHERE ARE THE COMMENTS GOING?
>> LET ME SEE, CONNOR, I GOT
RICH ARE TCHIE 21.
NOT RITCHIE RICH.
MAHOMES IS EASY MONEY.
DA TM
DATREON9 HAS MAHOMES AS A GIFT
FLEXING.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
AND I HAVE BAD SPORTS TAKES
HERE.
HE IS GOING WITH JOSH ALLEN.
HE WILL POP OFF.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
AND D-MOORE 521 HAS PATRICK
MAHOMES FLEXING IN THE COMMENTS.
CONNOR I WILL MAKE A DECISION.
PATRICK MAHOMES IS FLOODING MY
COMMENT SECTION.
PATRICK MAHOMES IS THE WINNER OF
TODAY'S SQUAD RIDE.
THAT'S WHO WE ARE RIDING WITH
TODAY.
LET ME PULL UP THE GRAPHIC SO I
CAN SHOW YOU GUYS.
SO I CAN SHOW YOU WHAT WE CAN DO
TO THE ODDS HERE, YOU SEE IT AT
THE PLUS 550, POOF.
JUST LIKE THAT.
YES, NOW, IT IS BOOSTED UP TO
PLUS 750, AND IT'S TIME RIGHT
NOW IN THE GIVE AWAY OF A JERSEY
AND 250 DOLLARS OF DK DOLLARS.
I HAVE, I HAVE RC ITALY, RC
ITALY SAID PATRICK MAHOMES, IT'S
TOO COLD AND WINDY IN BUFFALO, I
LOVE THAT TAKE.
THAT'S EXACTLY MY PERSPECTIVE OF
IT, SO I'M GOING TO HAVE YOU
WALK AWAY WITH A JERSEY.
RC ITALY, AND FOR THE 250DK
DOLLARS.
I HAVE I LOVE RANCH IN THE
COMMENTS.
SENDING GOOD VIBES AND SAYING
MAHOLM FORCE 400 YARDS.
WE NEED THAT.
WE NEED THE 400 YARDS TODAY.
SO, SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH 250DC
DOLLARS.
LET'S GO.
>> AND SHOUT OUT TO MICHAEL
BOWLING SAYING HE CANNOT BELIEVE
THAT HE PUTS KETCHUP ON STAKE,
THAT IS TABOO.
MA HOLMES IS THE GOAT RIGHT NOW,
HE CAN DO WHATEVER HE WANTS.
IT'S TIME TO GET IN THE MONEY
LINE MATCH UP.
EVERY GAME WE WILL BREAK IT DOWN
AND GO NO SPREADS.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT THEM AND LOOK
STRICTLY AT THE MONEY LINE.
THIS IS WILD CARD WEEKEND.
THE SLATE IS CRAZY.
BUT, BEFORE THAT, MAKE SURE YOU
GET ON DRAFT KINGS.
THEY HAVE SOMETHING REALLY,
REALLY SPECIAL FOR FIRST TIME
CUSTOMERS WHO CAN PLACE A MONEY
LINE BET OF $5 OR MORE DURING
THE POSTSEASON, AND IF YOUR BET
WINS, YOU WILL RECEIVE 280
DOLLARS IN FREE BETS.
IN ADDITION TO YOUR CASH
WINNINGS.
THAT IS A SWEET DEAL, WHAT ARE
YOU THINK SOMETHING.
>> THERE'S, THAT IS A PRETTY
SWEET DEAL, CONNOR.
ME AND CONNOR ARE GOING TO GO
GAME BY GAME, AND GIVE YOU OUR
FAVORITE MONEY LINE PICKS.
SO I NEED EVERYONE.
EVERYONE GET IN THE COMMENTS AND
TELL US WHAT YOU THINK BECAUSE,
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
I'M GIVING AWAY JERSEYS AND I AM
ALWAYS GIVING AWAY ANOTHER 250
OF DK DOLLARS, CONNOR.
AND I KNOW YOU GUYS WANT IT.
I WANT SOME OF THE DC DOLLARS.
THAT'S A PARLAY RIGHT THERE.
?
I WAS WONDERING HOW YOU AND I
GET IN ON THAT.
I GUESS WE WILL FIGURE IT OUT
AFTER THE SHOW.
KICKING IT OFF WITH THE GAME
THAT WILL BE STARTING NOT TOO
FAR AFTER WE ARE DONE.
WE HAVE THE RAIDER GOING TO
CINCINNATI AND THAT'S A PRETTY
ABOUT SPREAD FOR A WILD CARD
PLAYOFF GAME HEEFRMT PLUS SIX
THE RAIDERS ARE LOOKING AT, WE
ARE TALKING MONEY LINE RIGHT
NOW.
AND MAN, GREG, I LOOK AT THE
RAIDERS TEAM, AND IT'S BEEN A
ROLLER COASTER SEASON FOR THEM.
SHOUTOUT TO THEM FOR THE
ADVERSITY THEY HAVE DEALT WITH.
IT'S CRAZY THAT THEY ARE EVEN IN
THE PLAYOFFS BUT THE WAY THINGS
ENDED, THE WAY THEIR REGULAR
SEASON ENDED.
THAT WAS AN EMOTIONAL AND
PHYSICALLY TAXING GAME WHERE
THEY MIGHT HAVE TIRED LEGS GOING
ON THE ROAD THIS WEEKEND.
NOW, THEY HAVE PROVED EVERYONE
WRONG MULTIPLE TIMES.
BUT I LIKE THE BENGALS, GREG.
I MIGHT LIKE THE SPREAD, I LIKED
IT MORE WHEN IT WAS AT 5, 5.5
AND 6.
AND FOR MONEY LINE PURPOSES.
JOEY B COMES OUT AND GETS IT
DONE, HAS A BIG DAY.
I JUST DON'T KNOW, YOU SAID IT
BEFORE WE GOT ON THE SHOW TODAY
AND I AGREE.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE RAIDERS CAN
SCORE WITH THE BENG ALS
OFFENS
THAT IS WHAT HAS ME WORRIED.
WHAT RAIDER OFFENSE ARE WE
GETTING INSTODAY?
ARE WE GETTING THE ONE THAT IS
RUNNING AND GELLING AND PASSING
THE BALL AND INVOLVING WALLER OR
RENFROE, OR ARE WE GETTING THE
RAIDERS THAT ARE TAKING THE
SACKS AND NOT MOVING THE BALL
DOWN THE FIELD AND HAVING DEREK
CARR CHECK DOWN TO HIS
RECEIVERS?
WE REALLY DON'T KNOW WHICH
RAIDERS OFFENSE WE ARE GOING TO
GET.
BUT WE KNOW ABOUT THAT BENGALS
OFFENSE AND WHAT THEY DO.
SO, I THINK, I'M FEELING SAFE
WITH THE BENGALS MONEY LINE, BUT
LOOK AT THE OVER.
LOOK, LOOK AT THE OVER, TAKE A
GAR
GANDER AT IT.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE BENGALS
MONEY LINE.
>> ANYTHING WITH THE 50 SET AS
THE OVER, I WOULD SMASH IT.
IT COULD BE A SHOOTOUT AND THEY
ARE IN A POSITION TO RUN IT UP.
WHAT ARE THE COMMENTS SAYING
ABOUT THIS ONE.
YOU AND I SEE EYE TO EYE.
WE ARE GOING BENGALS ALL THE
WAY.
ARE THEY WITH US OR ARE THE
PEOPLE BUYING THE JUICE THAT THE
RAIDERS HAVE HAD TO USE TO CLOSE
OUT THE SEASON?
>> I SEE BENGALS ALL IN THE
COMMENTS.
I HAVE WATTAGES, HE SAID THAT HE
HAS JOE BURROW, BUFFALO WILD
WINGS GIFT.
WOW.
THAT'S GOOD CONTENT RIGHT THERE.
SO, SHOUTOUT TO WATTAGES, YOU
ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
>> ALL RIGHT, MOVING ON.
I HAVE TWO GAMES ON SATURDAY.
IT'S A GREAT, GREAT FIELDING.
WE SAID IT BEFORE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE TUNDRA
RIGHT NOW.
THE PATRIOTS HAVE BEEN IN THE
SPOT THIS SEASON.
THEY ARE GOING ON THE ROAD TO
BUFFALO.
IT WILL BELY C L
COLD.
IT WILL BE WINDY.
AND SHOUT OUT TO THE BILLS MAFIA
THAT FILL UP THE STADIUM.
THEY ARE PIFIVE POINT FAVORITES
AND WE ARE LOOKING AT THE MONEY
LINE.
AND WE ARE SEEING IF THEY HAVE
TO THROW THE BALL ON THE GAME.
ARE THEY GOING TO GO RUN, RUN,
RUN.
I LIKE THE BILLS.
I EVEN LIKE THE BILLS SPREAD
WHEN IT WAS AROUND 3.5, 4.5.
BUT MONEY LINE PURPOSES ONLY.
I'M ROLLING WITH THE BILLS
MAFIA.
IT'S HARD TO BIK AGAINST
BELICHICK, ESPECIALLY IN THE
SPOT AND I GET WHY PEOPLE ARE
AFRAID TO DO IT.
I THINK THE BILLS SIMPLY HAVE
THE PREMIUM TALENT AT
QUARTERBACK THAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE TO WIN IN THE PLAYOFFS.
AND MAYBE MACK JONES GETS THERE.
BUT THE WAY HE CLOSED OUT THE
SEASON, I'M NOT BELIEVING THAT.
RIGHT NOW, MAYBE NEXT YEAR,
MAYBE TWO YEARS FROM NOW.
RIGHT NOW, I'M AFRAID OF THAT.
>> YEAH, CONNOR, IN FACT, I TOLD
THE PRODUCERS, I TOLD THE
PRODUCERS I WAS ROCKING WITH
BUFFALO.
BUT TODAY, I WOKE UP AND I SAW
THE WHETHER THAT WILL BE IN
BUFFALO AND THAT JUST ME BACK TO
THE LAST TIME THAT THESE TWO
TEAMS FACED OFF IN COLD WEATHER.
THAT'S WHEN THE PATRIOTS, THEY
BARREL THREW THE BALL AND THEY
RAN THE BALL THE WHOLE ENTIRE
GAME.
THOSE MEMORIES ARE IN MY HEAD
AND I SEE THE PLUS MONEY,
CONNOR, SO, AND WE KNOW WHO BILL
BALE
BELICHICK IS, ONE OF THE
GREATEST COACHES TO COACH IN THE
NFL.
I THINK I WILL GO OVER TO THE
PLUS MONEY, CONNOR, AND SPRINKLE
A BIT ON THOSE PATRIOTS.
THAT'S WHO I'M ROCKING WITH IN
THIS ONE, CONNOR.
>> YEAH, I'M CURIOUS WHERE THE
COMMENTS GO.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS MATCH UP GO
BOTH WAYS ALREADY THIS REGULAR
SEASON.
SO, GREG, GET IN THE HANDY
DANDY.
WHAT DO THEY HAVE GOING ON OVER
THERE?
>> I'M IN THE COMMENTS, CONNOR,
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I GOT THE LIFE OF SMIDDY SAID
PATRIOTS, BELIEVE IN BIG MAC,
CONNOR.
WHERE THERE'S A BILL, THERE'S A
WAY.
I LIKE THAT.
I GOT OFFICIAL RONALD IN THE
COMMENTS SAID BILL MAFIA, YES,
JOSH ALLEN JUMPING THROUGH A
TABLE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, OFFICIALLY
RON
RONALD.
AND I HAVE ONE MORE.
LANDON FALLS HAS BILL BELICHICK
WINKING.
CONNOR.
EVERYONE THAT I MENTIONED YOU
ARE ALL WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
WE WILL SEE, CONNOR.
WE WILL SEE.
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT, MOVING ON
TO THE SUN BATHED SLATE OF 1:00.
WE HAVE THE EAGLES GOING DOWN
SOUTH TO TAKE ON TOM BRADY IN
TAMPA.
YOU NORMALLY THINK FLORIDA.
YOU THINK SUNSHINE AND
EVERYTHING IS ALL GRAVY.
IT'S JANUARY.
IT MIGHT NOT BE COLD.
BUT IT MAY BE RAINY DOWN THERE.
WE KNOW THE EAGLES TOP FLIGHT
RUSHING ATTACK COULD MAKE IT
INTERESTING.
NORMALLY YOU LOOK AT THE LINE,
RIGHT?
AND IT'S A BIG ONE.
IT'S BEEN AT 8.5.
NOW IT'S AT 8, BUT IT HAS HUNG
AROUND 8.5 THE ENTIRE WEEK.
THEY ARE BIG TIME UNDERDOGS THE
EAGLES.
WHERE I WAS TEMPTED, TEMPTED TO
TAKE THE UPSET, BUT YOU HAVE TO
USE YOUR BRAIN HERE.
I'M NOT BETTING AGAINST TOM
BRADY, WHO WAS A BIG TIME
FAVORITE YEAR IN THE FIRST ROUND
OF THE PLAYOFFS.
I THINK THE GAME WILL BE CLOSER
THAN PEOPLE THINK.
I DON'T THINK THAT THE BUCCS
BLOW THEM OUT.
BUT I WILL ROLL WITH BRADY AND
THE MONEY LINE.
ARE YOU WITH ME, GREG?
>> YEAH, THAT'S A SAFE ONE.
I'M ROLLING WITH BRADY AND THE
MONEY LINE THERE.
I SAW A STATISTIC THAT THE
EAGLES DID NOT BEAT ANY PLAYOFF
TEAMS THIS WHOLE YEAR.
I DON'T SEE THAT CHANGING ON
SUNDAY.
SO, I AM ROCKING WITH TOM AND
THE BOYS TO PUT THE SMACK DOWN
ON THE EAGLES ON SUNDAY.
>> I WOULD BE SURPRISED.
I WANT TO SEE THE COMMENT
SECTION.
IT WOULD BE SURPRISED IF ANYBODY
WAS FEELING BOLD ENOUGH TO GO
EAGLES MONEY LINE HERE.
ALTHOUGH THE BIRDS FANS, THEY
ARE ALWAYS LOUD AND PROUD IN THE
BLEACHER REPORT.
NOTHING WOULD SURPRISE ME.
>> CONNOR, I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE LOUD AND
PROUD IN THE COMMENTS.
D-MONEY.
D-MONEY IS IN THE COMMENTS
SAYING GO BIRDS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, D-MONEY.
I ALSO GOT INDERMAN IN THE
COMMENTS.
HE HAS AN EAGLES FLYING HIGH.
SHOUT OUT YOU, YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH HOODIES.
CONNOR, THE COMMENTS THEY MIGHT
THINK THE EAGLES ARE GOING TO
WIN.
BUT IT'S TOM BRADY.
>> SGREG NOT BUYING THE UPSET.
AND SPEAKING OF UPSET.
GOT ONE OF THE CLOSEST FRIENDS
OF THE WEEKEND.
GREG'S NINERS GOING ON THE ROAD
TO DALLAS AND IT'S ONLY A
THREE-POINT DIFFERENCE RIGHT
NOW.
LOOK AT THE MONEY LINE, GREG.
THIS IS THE FIRST UPSET I'M
GOING TO PICK HERE.
I'M GOING TO ROLL WITH YOUR
NINERS, I KNOW THE DALLAS FANS
WON'T LOVE THAT.
I JUST WORRY ABOUT WHAT THE
NINERS, YOU SAID IT OVER AND
OVER TODAY ON THE SHOW.
I WORRY ABOUT WHAT THE NINERS
RUSHING ATTACK CAN DO TO DALLAS
TO CONTROL THE CLOCK AND CONTROL
THE GAME, AND TRY TO TAKE IT OUT
OF DAK PRESCOTT'S HANDS.
AND THE COWBOYS IN BIG SPOTS.
I WILL BE HONEST WITH YOU, THEY
ARE STARTING TO WORRY ME A BIT
THIS YEAR.
SO, SHANAHAN HAS BEEN THERE
BEFORE.
I KNOW WITH JIM G, IT HAS NOT
BEEN SURPRISING.
THEY HAVE ENOUGH TALENT THAT
THEY FALL OFF A UPSET HERE.
ARE YOU ROLLING WITH YOUR BOYS?
ARE YOU LEANING THE SAME WAY?
>> YEAH, CONNOR, I'M GOING TO
ROCK WITH THE 49ers.
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF MATCH UPS.
THE 49ers LIKE TO RUN THE
FOOTBALL.
DALLAS DEFENSE, THEY STRUGGLE
RUNNING THE FOOTBALL.
USUALLY TYPICALLY IN THE NFL.
IF YOU HAVE A TEAM RUNNING OVER
AN OPPONENT, THAT TEAM USUALLY
WINS THE FOOTBALL GAME.
SO, LET'S NOT THINK TOO HARD
HERE.
LET'S, I MEAN, IT'S BEEN
HAPPENING TIME AFTER TIME IN THE
NFL.
IF THE TEAM IS ABLE TO RUN THE
BALL.
THEY ARE TYPICAL GOING WIN AND I
THINK THAT'S THE GAME PLAN THAT
THE SAN FRANCISCO 49 Aers WILL
HAVE AGAINST THE DALLAS TEAM ON
SUNDAY.
SO I'M ROCKING WITH THE NINERS.
>> I THINK IT WILL BE A BIG DAY
FOR DEEBO SAMUEL AS WELL.
IT'S NOT SAYING ANYTHING
SURPRISING.
HE IS ONE OF THE TOP FIVE
PLAYERS IN THE NFL THIS YEAR.
THE MATCH UP FOR HIM IS GREAT.
WE WILL GHETTO TO IT A BIT
LATER.
ALL RIGHT, THIS MIGHT BE THE
MOST CONFLICTED COMMENT SECTION
WE HAVE HERE, GREG.
I WANT TO HEAR WHERE IT'S GOING.
THIS IS AN OLD SCHOOL NFL MATCH
UP WITH DALLAS AND SAN
FRANCISCO.
WHICH WAY ARE THEY LEAN
SOMETHING.
>> IT'S AN OLD SCHOOL RIVALRY.
I HAVE MME, SAYS SF ALL THE WAY.
DEEBO WILL CARRY THE 49ers SHOUT
OUT TO YOU, MME, AND B HAWK 28
SAID THE NINERS, AND NINERS
UPSET.
WE THE BEST, 24.
THIS IS THE BEST, NINERS GOING
TO WIN BY THREE LATE GAME DRIVE
BY JIMMY G CALLING IT RIGHT NOW.
>> SHOUT OUT TO EVERYONE THAT I
SAID.
YOU ALL ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
I LOVE THAT TAKE THOUGH, CONNOR.
I CAN SEE THAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENING.
>> A LITTLE BELIEF IN JIMMY G,
THAT'S, IT'S NOT TO SEE THAT,
HONESTLY.
THE MAN IS TAKING HATE THIS
YEAR.
>> THE REST OF THE WILD CARD
WEEKEND HERE, WE HAVE THE CHIEFS
IN THE STEELERS, THE STEELERS
TEND TO ALWAYS HANG TOUGH NO
MATTER THE SITUATION.
BUT THERE'S NO DENYING THIS
SPREAD IS AN ABSENOLUTE MONSTER
FOR A PLAYOFF GAME.
IT'S BORDER LINE DISRESPECTFUL,
GREG.
IT'S ALMOST TWO TOUCHDOWNS.
STEELERS 12-POINT DOGS AGAINST
THE CHIEFS.
THIS IS GOING TO BE CHALKY.
I'M TAKING THE CHIEFS MONEY LINE
IN THE SITUATION.
I'M NOT TRYING TO REINVENT THE
WHEEL.
I THINK THE STEELERS COVER.
I DID PLACES A BET THAT THE
STEELERS COVER AT 12.5.
AND THE LINE HAS MOVED A BIT.
MAN, I DON'T THINK THAT WE CAN
OVER THINK THIS ONE.
RIGHT?
>> YEAH, NO.
LET'S NOT OVERTHINK THIS ONE AT
ALL.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE CHIEFS,
CONNOR, IN THIS ONE.
BIG BEN TOOK THE PODIUM EARLIER
IN THE WEEK.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF HE WAS
PULLING OUR LEG.
BUT HE SAID THAT THE STEELERS
SHOULD NOT BE HERE.
AND HE IS HONEST.
HE IS RIGHT.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE.
OR THEY GOT LUCKY LAST WEEK
WITH, WITH THE RAIDERS PULLING
IT OFF AT THE END THERE.
AND I'M JUST NOT.
I'M NOT THROWING THE CURVEBALL
HERE, CONNOR.
I'M NOT GOING TO TRY TO BE SUPER
MAN AND PICK THIS BIG MONEY
LINE.
NO I'M GOING TO PLAY IT SMART.
I'M ROCKING WITH PAT MAHOMESS
AND THE BOYS.
>> YEAH, DON'T BE A HERO, GREG.
WE HAVE HEROES IN AND COMMENTS?
ANYBODY BOLD ENOUGH TO SAY THE
STEELERS ARE NOT GOING TO COVER.
ARE GOING TO WIN?
LET ME SEE.
I GOT A STEELERS FAN, HIS NAME
IS STEVE.
KC MONEY LINE STEELERS COVER.
JJ -- I'M SORRY, T.J. WATT FOR
1.5 SACKS.
OKAY, I LIKE THAT, TAKE THAT.
IT'S A GOOD TAKE.
THERE'S NOT TOO MANY, OKAY, I
HAVE ANOTHER STEELERS FAN SAYING
LET'S GO STEELERS THEY ARE GOING
TO CLUTCH IT UP.
FL SPORTS 13, SHOUTOU OUT TO YO
AND THEN JOHN BRIGGS SAYING
CHIEFS WILL WIN THE GAME AND
COVER.
STEELERS SHOULD NOT BE IN THE
PLAYOFF.
MAHOMES WILL BALL.
THEY ARE BACK AND FORTH IN THE
COMMENTS.
THEY ARE BACK AND FORTH IN ONE.
I THINK I'M COMING PRETTY
CONFIDENT WITH PAT MAHOMES
TAKING CARE OF THE STEELERS.
>> IT'S NOT THE GAME WE ASKED
FOR, BUT IT'S THE ONE WE GOT.
THANKS FOR THE RAIDERS TAKING
THE FIELD GOAL.
>> FINAL MAUCH, WE HAVE MONDAY
NIGHT FOOTBALL IN THE PLAYOFFS
HERE.
ARIZONA.
GOING TO L.A. TO TAKE ON THE
RAMS.
ANOTHER TIGHT ONE.
ANOTHER ONE MUCH LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO, AND DALLAS.
WHERE THIS SPREAD IS EXTREMELY,
EXTREMELY CLOSE.
AND MAN, GREG, THIS IS ONE THAT
I HAVE GONE BACK AND FORTH ON
FOR A LONG TIME HERE.
ONLY A FOUR-POINT DIFFERENCE,
NOW, I THINK THE GAME WILL BE
CLOSE.
I WOULD NOT TAKE THE SPREAD
EITHER WAY AND IF I WAS, I WOULD
TAKE ARIZONA, BUT FOR MONEY
LINE, I WILL ROLL WITH THE RAMS
JUST BY FOLLOWING MY RULE OF
ARIZONA AT THIS POINT TO ME IS
BASICALLY THE CHARGERS OF THE
NFC, NIL SEE IT, I WILL NOT RELY
ON YOU.
I LIKE TYLER AND CLIFF, BUT THEY
HAVE NOT DONE IT IN THAT BIG
SPOT YET.
AND THE SAME COULD BE SAID ABOUT
MATT STAFFORD.
THERE'S NO DENYING THAT.
BUT YOU CAN'T SAY THAT ABOUT
SEAN McVEY.
THE MAN WENT TO A SUPER BOWL
BEFORE HE TURNED 35 YEARS OLD.
SO, THIS IS A TOUGH ONE.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A
DIFFERENCE OF A FIELD GOAL OR
LESS.
BUT MONEY LINE, I WILL TAKE THE
RAMS BECAUSE THEY ARE VETERANS
IN McBE VA AS A COACH.
AARON DONALD, AND JALEN RAMSEY.
GREG, ARE YOU ON THIS ONE?
IT'S A TOUGH ONE.
>> TO ME, IT'S A COIN FLIP AND
I'M BIASED BECAUSE I WILL BE IN
ARIZONA NEXT WEEK.
HOPEFULLY I CAN CHECK OUT A GAME
IN THE NICE ATMOSPHERE.
AND I THINK I WANT TO LEAN
ARIZONA HERE.
YOU MENTIONED, YOU MENTIONED
MATT STAFFORD.
AND SEAN McVEY.
MATT STAFFORD DID NOT LOOK GOOD
IN THE SECOND HALF LAST WEEK,
CONNORER.
HE DID NOT LOOK GOOD AGAINST THE
49ers.
HE ALSO NEEDS TO PROVE HIMSELF.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE CARDINALS
PROVING THEMSELVES.
I THINK MATT STAFFORD NEEDS TO
PROVE HIMSELF IN THE PLAYOFFS.
IN THE PLAYOFFS.
HE HAS TO GO WAYNE GAME.
HE HAS TO SHOW ME SOMETHING.
I LIKE THE CARDINALS OFFENSE.
I LIKE SEAN, I LIFE CLINGS BURY
AND I LIKE THE QUARTERBACK OUT
THERE, NO D-HOP, THAT ONE HURTS.
BUT I THINK THEY CAN GET IT DONE
IN THIS DIVISIONAL MATCH UP,
CONNOR.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER, THIS IS
THEIR THIRD TIME PLAYING THIS
YEAR.
SO A LOT OF ADJUSTMENTS WILL BE
MADE.
I LIKE THE CARDINALS IN THIS
ONE.
>> ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT GREG.
WE ONLY DISAGREED ON TWO PICKS.
TWONL GAMES OUT OF THE SIX.
LET'S MAKE IT INTERESTING FOR
THE PEOPLE.
LET'S TAKE ALL OF OUR PICKS.
TURN THEM IN TO A PARLAY AND I
WILL CUT YOU A DEAL RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE, BILL
S PK
ON MY END.
I CANNOT, BEING A NEW YORKER
TAKE THE PATRIOTS.
I'M SORRY, I CANNOT DO IT.
I CANNOT DO IT, BY LAW.
BUT I WILL MEET YOU IN THE
MIDDLE.
>> OKAY.
>> AND GO WITH ARIZONA.
ARE WE GOOD WITH THAT?
>> YES.
WE ARE GOOD WITH THAT.
BECAUSE I AM A BAY AREAIAN, AND
I CANNOT PICK A TEAM FROM L.A.
SO, WE CAN, WE CAN GET ALONG AND
WE CAN GO WITH THAT PARLAY IF
YOU GIVE ME ARIZONA, WE CAN TAKE
THE BILLS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THAT, THAT
PARLAY AND I KNOW, GREG, YOU
STILL HAVE MORE GIVE AWAYS TO GO
TO HERE.
WHERE ARE THE PEOPLE AT, ARE
THEY GOING TO RIDE WITH US ON
THIS ONE?
>> CONNOR LET ME SEE, I'M IN THE
COMMENTS, I'M GIVING AWAY A
JERSEY AND I'M GIVING AWAY DK
DOLLARS.
HERE WE GO.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS AND I SEE, I
SEE FL SPORTS 13.
HE SAID, LET'S GO RAMS.
THEY ARE GOING DESTROY THE
CARDINALS.
OKAY.
THAT'S NOT GOING WITH OUR
PARLAY, CARDINALS IS EASY MONEY.
HOLD ON, THE COMMENTS IS
JUMPING.
THE COMMENTS IS JUMPING, CONNOR,
I'M TRYING GO BACK TO FIND THE
ONE THAT I SAW.
HERE WE GO.
BIG MIKE 13 SAID CARDINALS EASY
MONEY WIN SOME DK MONEY, GLTHE
PRODUCER IS TELLING ME GIVE AWAY
THE DK DOLLARS.
LOOK.
I GOT, I GOT, I GOT SAL, SAL
CAMARI IS IN THE COMMENTS AND
LOOK IT, CONNOR.
HE IS THROWING, HE IS THROWING
BAD VIBES IN THE AIR.
GUESS WHAT, I TURNED BAD VIBES
IN TO GOOD VUBS.
THAT'S WHAT I DO.
HE SAID THE RAMS BECAUSE ARIZONA
IS INCONSISTENT.
GUESSES WHAT?
I'M SENDING YOU 250DK DOLLARS TO
DO WHATEVER YOU WANT TO DO WITH
IT.
I'M SENDING YOU GOOD VIBES
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE NEED
TODAY.
WE NEED ARIZONA TO BEAT THE
RAMS.
SO, A LITTLE REVERSE PSYCHOLOGY
THERE.
A LITTLE BIT REVERSER PSYCHOLOGY
AND PUTTING GOOD VIBES IN TO THE
ATMOSPHERE.
>> I LIKE IT, MAN.
AND I KNOW FOR ALL THOSE IN THE
COMMENTS GOING CRAZY THAT THEY
DID NOT GET A HOODIE, A JRZY.
DK DOLLARS.
I HAVE AN iPHONE COMING UP AND
WE HAVE MORE IN STORE.
DO NOT GO ANYWHERE.
WE HAVE LOCKS TO GIVE AWAY AS
WELL.
SHOUT OUT TO NENEVERYONE IN THE
COMMENTS SECTION.
$5 TO WIN $2$280 IT'S THE DEAL
A CENTURY.
THERE'S THE NEW DEAL THAT IF YOU
ARE NOT ON DRAFT KINGS BY NOW.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
WHATEVER TOUPT DO, BE A NEW
USER.
GET IN ON THERE.
OKAY.
BEFORE WE GET IN THE PLAYER
PROPS.
GREG, WE HAVE AIRPODS TO GIVE
AWAY.
DON'T YOU?
>> YES, SIR, THAT IS RIGHT.
CONNOR, EARLIER IN THE WEEK,
ASKED YOU GUYS ON THE
BR-BETTING, AND IN THE BR APP.
WHAT IS YOUR BEST MONEY LINE BET
FOR ON THIS WEEKEND?
AFTER GOING THROUGH THE KM
COMMENTS, CONNOR, EVERY GOING
THROUGH EVERY SINGLE COMMENT.
WE DECIDED THAT SNOOPY 21.53 WAS
THE WINNER.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE MONEY
LINE LOCK THERE IT IS.
I LIKE THAT A LOT THIS WEEK.
SO OIT'S JUICE, BUT I THINK IT'
A LOCK.
CONNOR DO YOU THINK IT'S A LOCK?
BRADY PLUS THE PLAYOFFS IS BUCKS
MONEY?
>> I WAS SAYING EARLIER, I
WANTED TO TAKE THE EAGLES, I
HAVE TO PROBLEM WITH THIS PICK.
IT'S MONEY LINE, IT'S BRAISY.
HE IS IN A HOME GAME.
>> YEAH.
>> I'M WITH SNOOIP PY ALL THE W.
THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
YOU DON'T PICK AGAINST BRADY IN
THE OPENING ROUND.
I DON'T CARE IF HE IS 70 YEARS
OLD, YOU DON'T DO IT.
CONGRATULATIONS TO SNOOPY.
WE ARE SENDING YOU A PAIR OF
AIRPODs.
iPHONE 13.
iPHONE 13, THE GIVE AWAY.
KEEP IT UP IN THE COMMENTS.
AND IT IS TIME FOR ONE OF MY
FAVORITE SEGMENTS THAT WE DO
HERE.
IT'S PROP LOCK OR DROP IT.
IF YOU LIKE IT, LOCK IT, IF NOT,
THROW IT IN THE TRASH, DROP IT.
>> WE HAVE SIX ON THE TABLE.
GET IN TO IT, LET THEM KNOW WHAT
WE HAVE GOT.
>> WE HAVE SIX ON THE TABLE.
WE WILL KEEP IT SHORT, SWEET AND
CONCISE.
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO IS LET US
KNOW IF YOU ARE ROCKING WITH THE
OVER OR UNDER.
IT'S SIMPLE.
LET'S GET TO IT.
CONNOR.
THE FIRST ONE, WE TALKED ABOUT
THE BENGALS TAKING ON THE
RAIDERS.
IT'S BEEN A COUPLE OF MINUTES,
ACTUALLY, JAYMAR CHASE IS
SITTING AT 71.5 RECEIVING YARDS,
CONNOR, I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH
THE OVER HERE, THE RAIDERS
DEFENSE DO NOT SCARE ME ONE BIT
AND WE KNOW WITH THE BENGALS,
AND WHAT THEIR OFFENSE LIKES TO
DO.
THEY LIKE TO PUSH THE BALL DOWN
THE FIELD AND THEY LOVE THE FEED
JAYMAR CHASE.
WHIC
WHICH WAY ARE YOU A RIDING?
YOU ROCKING WITH THE OVER OR
UNDER?
>> WITH THE OVERALL YEAR.
HE IS THE BEST WIDE RECEIVER.
HE IS GOING TO LIVE UP TO THE
HYPE.
HE IS BIGGER AND BRIGHTER WHEN
THE MOMENT IS BIGGER AND
BRIGHTER, OKAY, GREG.
HE WOODEN NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP
WHEN HE WAS 19 YEARS OLD.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE TWO WILL
DO ON THE PLAYOFF SCENE RIGHT
NOW HE WILL GET TO 72 PLUS
YARDS.
SHOUT OUT TO JAYMAR CHASE.
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT ONE.
DIGS, CORN.
I STRONGLY BELIEVE, SINCE THE
BEGINNING.
EVERY TIME WE MENTION DIGGS AND
THE BILLS, I WAS RIDING WITH
THEM SHOWING THEM MAD LOVE.
IT'S STILL LOVE.
BUT TODAY, THEY ARE IN THE COLD.
THEY ARE IN THE COLD.
YOU KNOW HOW I FEEL.
I DO NOT LIKE IT AT ALL.
AND THE LAST TIME THEY PLAYED IN
THE COLD ON, I DID NOT LIKE HOW
THE LAST TIME THEY PLAYED THE
PATRIOTS IN THE COLD, LET'S BE
SPECIFIC.
THE PATRIOTS IN THE COLD, I DID
NOT LIKE HOW THEY WERE PLAYING.
SITTING AT 70.5 RECEIVING YARDS.
I WILL GO UNDER HERE.
I WILL GO UNDER BECAUSE ABOUT
IT'S IN THE COLD.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I'M WITH YOU, GREG.
I LIKE THE BILLS TODAY.
I THINK THEY GET JOSH ALLEN
MOVING ON THE GROUND AND THEY
GET SINGLETARY INVOLVED AND NOX.
DIGGS WILL HAVE HIS.
HE HAS A BRUTAL MATCH UP.
HE WILL SEE ONE OF THE BEST
CORNERS IN THE NFL, WHO WILL GET
PAID BIG MONEY IN FREE AGENCY.
IT'S THE TUNDRA, IT'S A TOUGH
GAME TO BE AIRING IT OUT AND
GIVING DIGGS 15.
I AM WITH YOU.
I GENERALLY DON'T LIKE OVER
PROPS THAT MUCH WHEN THEY GET
HIGH LIKE THIS.
75.5 YARDS IS A LOT AGAINST NEW
ENGLAND AND IT'S A LOT IN THE
FRIGID WEATHER.
I'M WITH YOU, GOING UNDER.
>> CONNOR IS GOING UNDER WITH
ME.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT NAME.
BIG NAME RIGHT HERE.
ROB GRONKOWSKI, BIG TIME PLAYER.
SITTING AT 58.5 RECEIVING YARDS,
CONNOR.
I'M GOING TO RIDE WITH THE OVER,
SIMPLY BECAUSE ROB GRONKOWSKI
SHOWS UP WHEN THE LIGHTS, WHEN
THE LIGHTS ARE ON, ROB
GRONKOWSKI USUALLY SHOWS UP FOR
TOM BRADY.
AND I DON'T SEE THAT CHANGING
THIS WEEK AGAINST THE EAGLES.
SO, I'M GOING GO WITH THE OVER
HERE, CONNOR.
DO YOU SEE ROB GRONKOWSKI GOING
OVER OR UNDER HIS RECEIVING
YARDS TOMORROW?
>> I'M GOING WITH THE OVER.
THEY NEED HIM TO.
IT'S WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO IT'S
OPPORTUNITY.
WHEN GODWIN OR AB WAS OUT THERE,
I WOULD STAY SO FAR AWAY FROM
THIS ONE AND THE NUMBER WOULD BE
IN THE 30s OR AROUND 40, 42.
THE FACT IS, IT'S MIKE EDMONDS
AND THE GRONK SHOEMPT TOM BRADY
KNOWS.
THAT FORM BRADY IS A MAN OF
COMFORT WISELY.
HE GOES TO WHAT WORKS WHEN THE
BIGGEST GAMES ARE ON THE LINE.
THAT HAS BEEN ROB GRONKOWSKI FOR
A VERY LONG TIME.
IT WILL BE TO BE GRONKOWSKI.
I THINK HE GETS TO THE 60 TOTAL,
AROUND THERE.
>> I LIKE THAT, CONNOR.
WE HAVE SEEN IT BEFORE.
WE MIGHT SEE IT AGAIN.
MOVING ON, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
DEEBO SAMUEL HERE.
WE ARE TALKING RECEIVING YARDS
HERE, CONNOR.
RECEIVING YARDS ONLY.
WE KNOW THE LINE, WE KNOW THE
NINERS LIKE TO USE DEEBO OUT OF
THE BACKFIELD.
THEY LIKE TO HAVE HIM COMING IN
OFF THE JET SWEEP AND THEY LINE
HIM UP AT WIDE RECEIVER AND WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT RECEIVING
YARDS.
SITTING AT 64.5, CONNOR I'M GO
GOING WITH THE OVER.
>> I'M GOING GO WITH THE OVER.
SIMPLY BECAUSE A COUPLE OF
REASONS.
TRAYVON DIGGS.
TRAYVON DIGGS IS THE STAR
CORNERBACK OUT THERE FOR THE
DALLAS COWBOYS.
HE GIVES UP A LOT OF RECEIVING
YARDS.
ALTHOUGH, HE HAS A LOT OF
INTERCEPTIONS, HE GIVES UP A LOT
OF RECEIVING YARDS.
LOOK FOR THE DOUBLE MOVE, KYLE
SHANAHAN LOVES TO PULL OUT THE
DOUBLE MOVE WHEN IT'S LEAST
EXPECTED AND DEEBO, HE IS A YAC
GUY, IF YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
IS.
IT'S YARD AFTER CATCH.
HE IS ONE OF THE YAC THROWERS ON
THE 49ersS ANDS HE IS THE MVP OF
THE 49ers OFFENSE.
HOW DEEBO GOES, THE 49ers GO.
THE DEEP SHOT, OR MAKING HIM
CATCH THE SCREEN AND TAKING IT
DOWN THE FIELD.
CONNOR WHAT DO YOU THINK, OVER
OR UNDER?
>> IT'S A GREAT MATCH UP FOR
SAMUEL.
FIRST TEAM ALL PRO CORNER.
IT'S NICE AND FUN.
HE HAD A GREAT YEAR.
HE HAD TEN INTERCEPTIONS, GREAT
AMOUNT OF YARDS LIKE YOU SAID,
GREG.
AND IT'S A LOT.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
SOME DEFENSIVE COORDINATORS BEND
BUT DON'T BREAK STYLE.
YOU GET IN THE RED ZONE AND THAT
DOESN'T APPLY TO THIS PROP ON.
DEEBO SAMUEL, IT DOESN'T MATTER
ON THE GROUND, THROUGH THE AIR.
HE WILL HAVE A MONSTER DAY.
I LIKE HIM BETTER.
I THINK HE WILL DO BOTH AGAINST
DALLAS.
AND I THINK DEEBO, I WOULD SAY
DEEBO IF IT WAS IN THE 70s.
I LIKE THE OVER A LOT.
>> CONNOR IS LIKING THE OVER.
I'M LIKING THE OVER.
DEEBO OVER.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE NEXT
PERSON, CONNOR, TYREK, IS HE
SNUR
HURT, IS HE NOT HURT?
IF HE IS NOT HURT, I'M ROCKING
WITH IT.
I'VE SEEN IT TIME AFTER TIME.
PATRICK MAHOMES.
I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH THE OVER.
>> I'M GOING TO GO IN WITH THE
OVER AS WELL FOR TYREK.
THIS IS ONE THAT I'M AFRAID OF.
BUT IT COMES DOWN TO SOMETHING
YOU AND I ALWAYS SAY.
HE IS DUE.
HE HAS NOT HIT THE MARKER IN A
COUPLE OF WEEKS.
I THINK MIDDLE OF DECEMBER WAS
THE LAST TIME HE HAD A BIG TIME
GAME.
WHERE HE WOULD HAVE GONE OVER
THIS TOTAL.
SO, HE IS DUE.
THIS OFFENSE IS TOTALLY
DIFFERENT WITH HIM.
THAT'S WHAT IT COMES T
S DOW.
THEY ARE A WELL OILED MACHINE.
THAT IS NOT BECAUSE OF A DECOY,
THEY UTILIZE  MAHOMES GUY.
I WILL TAKE HILL.
>> IT IS RISKY.
IS HE HEALTHY OR IS HE NOT?
MOVING TO ON SOMEONE THAT I KNOW
WHO IS, RELATIVE THELY HEALTHY,
AT THIS POINT IN THE SEASON.
IT'S COOPER CUPP.
THE MONDAY RECEIVING YARDS IS
106.5.
NOW, CONNOR, IT'S A LOT.
AND IT'S COOPER CUPP AND LAST
WEEK, I WAS ROCKING WITH THE
COOPER CUPP OVER.
AND WITH THIS, I WANT TO DO THE
SAME.
SIMPLY BECAUSE IT'S MATTHEW
STAFFORD'S SAFETY BLANKET.
YOU MENTIONED ROB GRONKOWSKI FOR
TOM BRAID.
THEY DON'T HAVE AS MANY RINGS.
LET'S NOT GO THERE IN THE
COMPARISON.
AS FAR AS IN THE SAFETY BLANKET.
HE IS MOVING CONSISTENTLY.
YOU WANT HIM TO GO OVER HIS
RECEIVING YARDS.
>> I'M GOING TO GO UNDER.
THEY ARE BETTER COACHED THAN
THEY ARE TALN'ENTTALENTED.
THAT SPEAKS TO EVERYTHING THAT
THEY WILL TRY TO WIPE OUT COOPER
CUPP, CAN THEY CONTAIN HIM?
CAN THEY SAY, BEAT US WITH
ANYBODY ELSE.
I'M GOING OVER HERE.
THIS IS A GIANT TOTAL.
HE HAS EARNED THIS.
THE BEST FANTASY PLAYER THIS
YEAR.
THIS MAY SURPRISE.
I WILL GO UNDER FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN A WHILE.
>> CONNOR IS GOING UNDER HERE.
I WILL SEE WHAT THE COMMENTS
ARE.
I'M GIVING AWAY A JERSEY.
6 FOR 6,AL  AL
6 FOR 6,AL  A
L OVER.
I GOT C BIG V, THEY SAY
CARDINALS CAN SHUT HIM DOWN.
WATCH, THINK THINK THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT COOPER CUPP.
CONNOR, JUST FOR THAT.
I WILL GIVE YOU A JERSEY.
HE IS GOING TO SHUT DOWN COOPER
CUPP.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN BUY YOURSELF
SOMEBODY WITH A CUPP JERSEY.
WE HAVE AL MENDOZA, I'M PUTTING
THE PROPS ON THE PARLAY AND
LOOKS LIKE MONEY TO ME.
THANKS FOR ALL THE -- YOU KNOW,
CONNOR, I LIKE THAT.
AND I WILL SEND HIM GOOD VIBES
AND SEND HIM 250DK DOLLARS.
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN PUT A PROP ON,
PUT ANOTHER PROP BET IN WITH
THAT 250DK DOLLARS.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
JERSEYS AND 250 TLAR$250 TLADK.
>> iPHONE 13 GIVE AWAY COMING
UP.
I HAD A CHANCE TO CATCH UP WITH
JOIN FOR THE INSIDE SCOOP ON THE
HOTTEST PLAYOFF MARKETS RIGHT
NOW.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ALL RIGHT, NOW, VERY HAPPY TO
WELCOME IN JOHNNY FROM DRAFT
KINGS.
JOHNNY, I HAVE TO START OFF WITH
AN EASY ONE.
WHO ARE YOU SEEING THE MOST
SUPER BOWL BETS ON?
THE WINNER, THE WINNER OF THE
SUPER BOWL?
WHO ARE YOU SEEING THE MOST
ACTION ON THERE?
THE PLAYOFF FIELD WAS SET.
THEY CONTINUE TO DRAW MONEY.
RIGHT NOW, THEY ARE SITTING AT
PLUS 380, WHICH IS 19-5.
THAT'S THE LOWEST PRICE THEY
HAVE BEEN ALL SEASON.
ONE OTHER THING , THE TITANS
ARES ALSO GETTING A NICE LITTLE
PUSH IN THE FUTURE'S MARKET WITH
THE ANTICIPATION OF DERRICK
HENRY RETURNING AND ENHANCING
THE CHANCES TO GET IT BACK.
NO SURPRISE TO SEE A LOT OF
ACTION ON THE NUMBER ONE SEED
COMING IN.
STILL, THEY ARE FAIR ODDS.
YOU MENTIONED FUTURES, OUT OF
THE FUTURE BETS THAT YOU HAVE TO
WIN THE SUPER BOWL.
WHAT IS THE BIGGEST ONE YOU HAVE
LEFT THAT IS STILL ALIVE GOING
IN TO THE START OF THE
POSTSEASON?
>> I REMEMBER A BET THAT CAME
IN, THAT WAS APPROXIMATELY ABOUT
118, $120,000 TO WIN $1.1
MILLION ON THE RAMS AT 8-1.
AND THERE'S STILL, A FEW OTHERS
OUT THERE THAT ARE SIMILAR TO
THAT.
SO, FOR THE BOOK, YOUR BIGGEST
LIABILITY TO WIN, WHATEVER IT
WOULD COST THE BOOK TO MOST AND
THE SMALLEST?
>> WELL THE PATS ARE THE
BIGGEST.
YOU KNOW, PATS HAVE BEEN TAKING
MONEY FOR THE LAST HALF OF THE
YEAR.
THEY ARE FOLLOWED BY NOT TOO FAR
BEHIND THE PACKERS AND THE CARDS
AND STEELERS ARE THE LIGHTEST
LIABILITY.
THE SEASON STARTED AND YOU WOULD
HAVE RECEIVED THE PRETTY NICE
PRICE.
AND THEY STARTED SO STRONG, AND
AT THE PRICE WENT DOWN QUICKLY.
NO ONE HAS ANY FAITH IN THEM.
>> STEELERS FANS, NOT CALL THEM
BIASED.
>>> THE DRAFT KINGS IS OFFERING
A LOT OF NEW STUFF THIS YEAR.
WHAT IS THE MOST POPULAR MARKET
THAT YOU HAVE SEEN THIS YEAR.
>> BY FAR, THE SAME GAME,
PARLAYS, THEY WERE THE BIGGEST
GOING VERY WELL.
FIRST QUARTER MONEY LINE.
OFFENSIVE SCORE ON THE FIRST
DRIVE OF THE GAME.
THAT'S A YES NO TYPE OF PROP.
AND ANOTHER THAT WAS BET STRONG
WAS THE PLAYER TOUCHDOWN
RECEPTION.
I KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF FUN WITH
THE NO SCORE FIRST DRIVE ON THE
SHOW.
EVERY WEEK.
JOHNNY, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
TAKING TIME TODAY.
GOOD STUFF FROM JOHNNY AS
ALWAYS, GIVING YOU THE INSIDE
SCOOP OF WHERE EVERYONE IS
LAYING THE MONEY RIGHT NOW.
AND OBVIOUSLY EVERYONE IS ON THE
PACKERS, EVERYONE IS LOVING THE
SAME GAME PARLAYS.
BUT ONE MARKET YOU AND I WILL
SCORE ON THE FIRST DRIVE.
RIGHT NOW.
DRAFT KINGS IS BOOSTING IT FOR
ALL SIX GAMES THIS WEEK.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS HERE,
GREG.
WE MIGHT AS WELL GET THE BOARD
UP AND SHOW EVERYONE WHAT WE ARE
WORKING WITH FOR WILD CARD
WEEKEND.
IT'S 125.
YOU AND I THINK, LOVE THE VEGAS.
ESPECIALLY IF BURROW CAN GET
THERE EARLY.
THE STEELERS, A LOCK, I'M GIVING
AWAY HOODIES.
GIVING AWAY A JERSEY AND GIVING
AWAY 250DK DOLLARS TO MY
FAVORITE COMMENTERS.
ALL RIGHT, BACK TO THE MATCH UPS
HERE.
LET'S THAT TALK ABOUT THE
FAVORITE ONE AND THEN IN THE
COMMENTS THEY CAN RIDE WITH US.
THEY CAN GO WITH THEIRS.
WHY DON'T CARE, THERE'S NO BIAS
HERE.
IT'S GOT TO BE ARIZONA, AND THE
RAMS.
YOU DON'T JUST GET A TOUCHDOWN,
YOU NEED THE FOLD GOAL.
THE TEAMS HAVE EXTRA REST, THEY
ARE THE MONDAY PICKS.
OKAY, SO, IT'S THE TUNDRA.
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT I WAS GOING TO
SAY.
I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT OUTITY
ALL GAME.
SO YOU LIKE THAT ONE FOR THE NO
SCORE FIRST DRIVE.
AND YOU KNOW, WE GETTING IT
BOOSTED, THAT MINUS $125.
ARE YOU ROCKING WITH THAT ONE
WITH ME?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT YOU NEED
TO OVER THINK THAT ONE.
I THINK PEOPLE WOULD LIKE THE
COIN FLIP OF THE STEELERS AND
CHIEFS.
IF THE STEELERS GET THE BALL.
THE DEFENSE IS UP AND DOWN.
THEY DON'T COME OUT FIRING.
BUT GREG, LET'S BE REAL.
YOU GO WITH IT, WITH THE
CONDITIONS AT THIS POINT.
IT'S GOT TO BE THE PATRIOTS AND
BILLS.
ARE THE COMMENTS AGREEING, ARE
THEY SIDING WITH THAT?
>> THE ELEMENTS ARE DEFINITELY A
FACTOR.
I GOT THREE EAT 77 SAID BILLS
PAID ROTS, IT'S TOO DANG COLD
FOR POINTS TONIGHT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
PLEASE EXPLAIN HOW THE NFC EAST
WILL STILL GET DID IT RESPECT
AR
-- STILL GET DISRESPECTED WHEN
WE SEND TWO TO THE PLAYOFFS.
I DON'T KNOW, BUT I'M SENDING
YOU MONEY YOU CAN TURN THE CROWN
UP SIDE DOWN AND PUT A PARLAY
IN.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
YOU SEE HOW WE DO IT, CONNOR?
SEE HOW WE TURN NEGATIVITY IN TO
POSITIVITY.
BAD VIBES IN TO GOOD VIBES.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, VG73, ARE YOU
ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A DK
DOLLARS, BROTHER.
>> EVEN THE ANGRY COMMENTERS GET
REWARDED EVERY NOW AND THEN ON
THE SQUAD RIDE.
HOPEFULLY COMING BACK WITH SOME
BETTER VIBES AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR THOSE AS
WELL.
BECAUSE IT IS A GREG AND I'S
FAVORITE TIME OF THE SHOW.
IT IS BOLDEST BETS.
WE ARE NOT LOOKING FOR THE MINUS
125s OF THE WORLD OR THE PLUS
200s.
WE ARE LOOKING TO GET BOLD, WE
ARE LOOKING TO GET CRAZY.
YOU CAN STILL WIN.
GREG, YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHAT YOU
ARE GIVING AWAY AND WHAT THEY
HAVE TO DO?
>> CONNOR, I'M GIVING AWAY.
GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND GIVING
AWAY JERSEYS AND I'M GIVING AWAY
THEM DK DOLLARS.
250 OF THEM.
TO BE EXACT.
SO, WE, WE, CONNOR.
LET'S JUST GET RIGHT TO IT.
BRO.
LET'S JUST JUMP RIGHT IN.
WHO YOU ARE YOU ROCKING WITH?
WHAT IS YOUR BONUS BET?
>> GREG, I KNOW YOU LIKE THIS
ONE.
THIS IS THE JOEY B SPECIAL.
GOING OVER.
YOU SAID IT, YOU DO NOT TRUST
THE RAIDERS SECONDARY.
HE WITH LIKE BURROWS OFFENSE.
WHERE ARE YOU AT THIS WEEK?
>> I LIKE THAT PRODUCERS WAS
LIKE CONNORER HAS JOE BURROW.
TYREK HILL TRAVIS KELSEY.
TO COMBINE FOR OVER 2.5
TOUCHDOWNS.
CONNOR.
I NEED THREE BETWEEN THE TWO OF
THEM.
I'M PRAYING THAT MY GUY, TYREK
IS HEALTHY.
I FEEL GOOD.
I THINK, WE KNOW WHAT THE CHIEFS
LIKE TO DO.
THEY LIKE THE FEET, THEY ARE
PLAY MAKERS AND THESE ARE TWO OF
THEIR BIGGEST PLAY MAKERS ON THE
OFFENSIVE SIDE OF THE BALL.
THAT PATRICK MAHOMES FEEDS
CONSISTENTLY.
I'M ROCKING WITH KELSEY TO GIVE
ME THREE TOUCHDOWNS COMBINED.
>> YOU MAY GET TWO FROM KELSEY.
WE KNOW WHAT THEY CAN DO WITH
THE BIG PLAYS.
OUR ODDS ARE THE SAME.
WE WENT BOLD FOR WILD CARD
WEEKEND.
IS ANYONE CRAZY ENOUGH TO RIDE
WITH US OR THROW IN THEIR OWN
BOGUS BETS IN THE FRAY THIS
WEEKEND?
WHAT DO WE GOT?
GAVE YOU A SUNSET EMOJI WITH A
LOCK AND A MONEY BAG.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY FOR THAT ONE, D-MONEY.
I HAVE JOHN BRIGGS.
THIS IS A BOLD TAKE.
RAIDERS MONEY LINE IS A LOCK.
EVERYONE IS ON IT.
I HAVE RAIDERS MONEY LINE HE IS
THE BEST ROUTE RUNNER.
HE WILL GET IN THE END ZONE AND
HE IS GOING GET IN THE END ZONE,
HAD TWO TOUCHDOWNS LAST WEEK.
COME WITH THE 250DK MONEY.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY.
DON'T GO NOWHERE.
I'M ABOUT TO GIVE AWAY AN iPHONE
IN THE NEXT SEGMENT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IS IT THE PLAYOFFS IF WE ARE NOT
TALKING FUTURES.
WE ARE LOOKING AHEAD AND WE ARE
ASKING YOU.
WHO'S THE BEST BET TO WIN THE
SUPER BOWL?
IT'S AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
THAT IS WHAT EVERYONE HAS THEIR
EYES ON FOR THIS ONE.
SO, LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
CURRENT CHAMPIONSHIP ODDS TO DO
EXACTLY THAT.
COMING IN BIG ON THE PACKERS.
AND THEN YOU HAVE A WIDE ARRAY
OF TEAMS THAT ARE PRETTY EVEN.
THE RAMS BIG TIME UNDERDOGS,
GREG, YOU HAVE BEEN HOLDING ON
TO THE iPHONE FOR A LONG TIME.
IT'S TIME TO LET IT GO.
I NEED EVERYONE TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME, WHO YOUR
LOCKS ARE TO WIN THE
CHAMPIONSHIP, IF YOUR COMMENT
MATCHES THE TEAM CHOSEN BY THE
PRIZE, L YOU CAN WIN AN iPHONE
13, CONNOR.
THAT'S HOW YOU CAN DO IT.
IT'S TIME TO SPIN THE WE'LL.
WE HAVE HEARD ABOUT THE WHEEL.
I WANT TO SEE, WHO IT LANDS ON.
WHO IS WINNING, WHO IS TAKING IT
HOME.
IF YOUR PICK MATCHES THE WHEEL,
THE WHEEL IS SPINNING.
AND THERE IT IS.
TLTS.
IT'S THE PACKERS.
THE PACKERS ARE THE WINNERS,
CONNOR.
LET'S GO TO THE COMMENTS.
I AM GOING TO READ THE COMMENTS.
I WILL READ THE COMMENTS WHO
THEY ARE ROCKING WITH, AND I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHO YOU THINK
WILL WIN THE SUPER BOWL.
I GOT PACKERS IS ALL IN THE
COMMENTS.
Q
QBEAST, I THINK THAT IS IT, BRO.
YOU WILL CALL IT, CONNOR, I WILL
GIVE HIM THE iPHONE RIGHT THERE
JUST LIKE THAT.
HE CALLED IT.
CONNOR, TALK TO ME.
WHO DO YOU THINK WILL WIN IT
INSTALL.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE GOING
WITH THE FAVORITE.
THEY ARE TELLING YOU, IT'S A
WIDE OPEN PLAYOFF FIELD.
NOBODY IS BELOW THE 300 MARKER.
I HAVE A TICKET TO GRIEB BAY.
THEY ARE GETTING HEALTHY AT THE
RIGHT TIME.
RODGERS IS ON A DIFFERENT LEVEL
RIGHT NOW.
ADAMS IS THE BEST WIDE RECEIVER
IN FOOTBALL.
AND I CAN'T SAY IT ENOUGH.
DEFENSIVELY, THEY ARE GETTING
THEIR STARS BACK AND ADDING TO A
DEFENSE THAT HAS BEEN SO GOOD
WHEEL DEALING WITH INJURIES.
YOU HAVE TO.
THEY ARE THE NUMBER ONE SEED.
WHERE ARE YOU AT, GREG?
BEST SUPER BOWL BOWL FET HERE.
>> I WILL EXPLAIN WHY I THINK
THE 49ers.
I ALSO HAVE GREEN BAY, I THINK
THEY CAME OUT THIS YEAR AND THEY
SHOWED EVERYONE.
THEY SHOWED EVERYONE WHAT THEY
ARE.
AARON RODGERS LOOKS GREAT.
HE LOOKS GREAT.
YOU MENTIONED THE HOME FIELD
ADVANTAGE THAT THEY HAVE AT
LAMBEAU.
THAT'S BIG.
CONNORER, A LOT OF TEAMS DON'T
WANT TO GO AND FACE THEM AT
LAMBEAU IN THE TUNDRA, LIKE YOU
LIKE TO CALL IT N THE COLD.
SO I LIKE THE GREEN BAY PACKERS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE SAN
FRANCISCO 49ers AND THE REASON I
PUT THE FUTURE IN ON HIM A
COUPLE OF WEEK AGS.
CORN, THEY ARE A TEAM THAT LIKES
TO RUN THE FOOTBALL.
IN THE NFL, IF YOU HAVE A TEAM
THAT LIKES TO RUN THE FOOTBALL.
MANCHLTH OF THE TIME, IF THEY
ARE SUCCESSFUL IN THE GAME, THEY
USUALLY WIN THE GAME.
YOU MENTIONED GETTING HEALTHY.
THE 49ers, THAT DEFENSE HAS
GOTTEN HEALTHY.
THEY HAVE GOTTEN HEALTHY AT
CORNERBACK AND LINEBACKER.
THE DIFFEREFENSIVE LINE, THEY H
GOTTEN HEALTHY.
THEY HAVE GOTTEN HEALTHY AT THE
RIGHT TIME.
A LOT OF TEAMS MAY IS H-- THEY
ONE OF THE HOTTEST TEAMS IN THE
NFL IN THE LATTER WEEKS.
SO, I LIKE BOTH OF THEM.
I LIKE THE 49ers AND I LIKE THE
GREEN BAY PACKERS.
SPRINKLE FUTURES ON BOTH.
AND YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE BEEN
THERE.
THEY HAVE BOTH BEEN THERE.
YOU RIGHT WITH EXPERIENCE IN THE
POSTSEASON.
I DON'T MIND THE PACKERS AT ALL.
WE WILL SEE A BIT OF AN UPSET
THIS WEEK.
SO, THAT WAS A WRAP.
THANK YOU TO OF COURSE, THE LOCK
LEGENDS THAT MAKE THE SHOW SO
GREAT.
WE HAVE HAD ATLAS RETURNING.
THE REAL DAY-DAY MAKING A GREAT
DEBUT GOING WITH THE JOE BURROW
PICK WHICH OBVIOUSLY I AM A BIG
FAN OF.
GREG IS A BIG FAN OF AND OF
COURSE, THE OLD SCHOOL LEGEND,
AND THANK YOU TO THE COMMENTERS.
YOU MAKE THE SHOW THAT'S WHAT
MAKES IT SPECIAL.
HOPEFULLY YOU MAKE A GOOD BET.
DON'T FORGET TO REVIEW ALL OF
THE CUSTOM BOOSTS.
THE BOOSTS ON THE QUARTERBACK
PROP, THAT WAS PATRICK MAHOMES.
YOU HAVE A TON OF OPTIONS.
JUMP IN ON THE TUNDRA, AND I
DON'T THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE
A TON OF POINTS EARLY IN THE
GAME AS THEY FEEL IT OUT.
WE HAVE THE $5 TO WIN $280.
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
IF YOU BET ON A MONEY LINE, AND
HAMMER THE OVER IS GOING ON
RIGHT NOW.
DRAFT KINGS IS WEARING ME OUT.
THEY HAVE SO MANY DIFFERENT
OVERS.
HAMMER THE OVER, IT'S A FREEBIE,
IF YOU DO THIS ONE, YOU WILL
TAKE HOME MONEY.
THEY KEEP DROPPING THE POINT
TOTAL.
IT'S GOING DOWN.
LAST TIME I LOOKED AT IT BEFORE
WE STARTED THE SHOW, IT'S AROUND
14 AND CONTINUING TO DESCEND UP
UNTIL KICKOFF.
LIKE I SAID, NOW THEY ARE SAYING
IT'S DOWN 11.
THIS THING IS JUST GOING TO DROP
IN TO THE SINGLE DIGIT NUMBERS.
PLEASE SEND US YOUR REACTION
VIDEOS THIS WEEKEND AND DROP
YOUR REAL TIME TAKE ON SOCIAL.
AND IN THE SPORTS BETTING
COMMUNITY ON THE BLEACHER REPORT
APP, JOIN US NEXT SATURDAY.
WE ARE BACK HERE.
SAME TIME, SAME PLACE.
2:00 P.M. EASTERN.
GREG HAS TONS OF GIVE AWAYS.
HE HAS THE GOOD STUFF.
HE HAS THE TAKES AND HOODIES AND
DK DOLLARS.
THANK YOU EVERYONE, CATCH YOU
NEXT TIME.